why is Saudi Arabia failing to copy
Dubai by far one of the biggest limiting
factors holding back Saudi Arabia is the
negative stigma surrounding the country
whether it's true or not the Western
media has painted an extremely negative
picture when it comes to Saudi Arabia
something else to consider is that
people don't associate Saudi Arabia with
vacation in the first place Dubai had to
work a decades to create this
Association and the primary way to
accomplish this was through their
Airlines Saudi Arabia however does not
have such an airline the average person
likely doesn't even know what their
Airline is called or what the capital of
Saudi Arabia is